so we have the differential equation the
derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to Y over six times four minus y
and what we have plotted right over here
is the slope field or a slope field for
this differential equation and we can
verify that this indeed is is a slope
field for this differential equation
let's draw a little table here so let's
just verify a few points so say X Y and
dy DX so let's say we start with I don't
know let's start with this point right
over here 1 comma 1 when X is 1 and Y is
1 well when I look at the differential
equation 1 6 times 4 minus 1 so it's 1 6
times 3 which is 3 6 which is 1/2 and we
see indeed on the slope field they
depicted they depicted the slope there
if a solution goes to that point and
right at that point
it's slope would be 1/2 and as you see
it's actually only dependent on the Y
value it doesn't matter what X is as
long as Y is 1 dy DX is going to be 1/2
and you see that's why when X is 1 and
1/2 and Y is 1 you still have a slope of
1/2 and 4 as long as Y is 1 all of these
all of these sampled points right over
here all have a slope of 1/2 so that
that's you know we're just looking at
that that makes us feel that this that
this slope field is consistent with this
differential equation but let's try a
few other points just to feel a little
bit better about it and then we will use
the slope field to actually visualize
some solutions so let's say added let's
do an interesting point let's say we
have this point actually no that's
that's it that's it a half point let's
say we have this this let's see I want
to do let's say we do this point right
over here so that's X is equal to 1 and
Y is equal to 6 and we see the way the
differential equation is defined it
doesn't matter what our X is it's really
dependent on the Y that's going to drive
the slope but we have 6 over 6 which is
1 times 4 minus 6 which is negative 2 so
it's negative 2 so we should have a
slope of negative 2 and it looks like
that's what they depicted so as long as
Y is 6 we should have a slope of
negative to have a slope of negative two
and you see that in the slope field so
hopefully you feel pretty good that this
is the slope field for this differential
equation if you don't I encourage you to
keep keep verifying these points here
but now let's actually use the slope
field let's actually use this to
visualize solutions to this differential
equation based on points that the
solution might go through so let's say
that we have a solution that goes
through this point right over here so
what is that solution likely to look
like and if once again it's going to be
a rough approximation well right at that
point it's going to have a slope just as
a slope field shows and as our Y
increases it looks like our slope it
looks like our slope so at this point I
should be actually let me let me undo
that so this if I keep going up at this
point when Y is equal to two I should be
parallel to all of these these segments
on the slope field at Y is equal to two
and then it looks like the slope starts
to decrease as as we approach Y is equal
to four and so if I had a solution that
went through this point my guess is that
it would look something and then now the
slope decreases again as we as well as
we approach Y is equal to zero and of
course we see that because if when y
equals zero this whole thing is zero so
our derivative is going to be zero so a
reasonable solution might look something
like this so this gives us a clue well
look if a solution goes through this
point this right over here might might
be what it looks like but what if it
goes through I don't know what if it
goes through this point right over here
well then it might look like it might
look like this by the same exact logic
so it might look like this so just like
that we're starting to get a sense we
don't know the actual solution for this
differential equation but we're trying
to get a sense of what what type of
functions what type of functions are the
class of functions that might satisfy
the differential equation but what's
interesting about this slope field it
looks like there's some you know there's
some interesting
stuff you know any if we have if our
solution includes points between where
the y values between 0 and 4 it looks
like we're gonna have solutions like
this but what if we had Y values that
were larger than that or that were less
than that or exactly exactly
0 or 4 so for example what if we had a
solution that went through this point
right over here well at that point right
over here the slope field tells us that
our slope is zero so our Y value is not
going to change it as long as our Y
value doesn't change our Wi-Fi was going
to stay at 4 so our slope is going to
stay 0 so we actually already found this
is actually a solution to the
differential equation it's y is equal to
4 is a solution to this differential
equation so Y is equal to 4 y is equal
to 4 and you can verify that that is a
solution when y is equal to 4 this right
hand side is going to be 0 and the
derivative is 0 for y is equal to 4 so
that is a solution to the differential
equation and the same thing for y is
equal to 0 that is also a solution to
the differential equation now what if we
included points what if we included this
point up here and actually let me do it
in a different color so that you could
see it let's say our solution include at
that point well then it might look
something it might look something like
this and once again I'm just using the
slope field as a guide to give me an
idea of what the slope might be as my
curve progresses as my solution
progresses so a solution that includes
the point 0 5 might look something like
this and once again it's just another
clue a solution that includes the point
0 negative 1 and 1/2 might look
something like might look something like
this so anyway hopefully this gives you
a better appreciation for why slope
fields are interesting if you have a
differential equation that just involves
the first derivative and some X's and
Y's this one only involves the first
derivative and Y's we can plot a slope
field like this
is not too much trouble if we since you
just keep solving for the slopes and
then we can use that slope field to get
a conceptual or visual understanding of
what the solutions might look like given
points that the solutions might actually
contain